>> Sandy Blythe.
>> Hey folks, come on
down. Welcome back.
Hope you all have had
a great first day
of Faculty Summit.
I should thank of course
first and foremost,
the speakers from
our breakout sessions.
Especially, our
university partners
who presented with us.
I thought the topics
were top-notch
and I very much appreciate all of
the speakers for
the evident care and
effort that they put into
their presentations.
So, thank you to all of the
breakout speakers,we've
got more to come.
I'm particularly excited
about the next topic.
As I said this morning,
I thought that was
an amazing canvas
of opportunity in
Systems Research,
and it's not just for great
research and instruction.
I think there's an opportunity
for entrepreneurship as well.
We've got a panel of people
who have had success in
translating
their Systems Research
into entrepreneurial success,
and I'm very pleased to introduce
our first panelist from
Microsoft Research,
Ranveer Chandra.
Ranveer has a career
at Microsoft as
a Principal Researcher.
He's received himself
over 85 patents
here in the US and
more on the way.
He's been running
Battery projects
and TV white spaces project.
He's probably best
known at the moment for
running a project
called FarmBeats,
which is really an internal
start up at Microsoft.
It started as a
research project in
IOT for digital agronomy,
and has moved now out
into customers' hands.
It is making a difference
in reducing the cost
and increasing
the viability of agriculture as
we face a future of
increasing scarcity.
He's been well-recognized,
published in a number of venues,
The Economists,
The Wall Street Journal.
He's an MIT TR35,
the technology TR35 winner
as a top innovator.
So, really has a lot to say about
entrepreneurship along
with his two co-panelists.
So with that, let me
introduce Ranveer.
Here you go. Thank you.
>> Thank you Sandy and
thank you all for coming.
Today we have
an exciting 35 minutes,
where we have two
distinguished panelists.
We'll be discussing about
Systems Research and
Entrepreneurship.
The two distinguished
professors we have,
one is Dawn Song,
from UC Berkeley, and Matei from
Stanford University.
Welcome Dawn.
>> Thank you.
>> Welcome Matei.
>> So both Dawn and Matei,
are very well known faculty.
Dawn is a professor
at UC Berkeley.
Her papers are very well cited.
In addition to that,
she's also received
multiple awards,
the MacArthur Fellowship,
the Sloan Fellowship,
the MIT TR-35 Award,
and the list goes on and
on, and we won't go there.
For this session, what's
exciting is that she's done
multiple startups Insighter
Security sold to Fire I.
The other one Mendel Security,
and the third one
which she's doing
right now is on Oasis Labs.
She does research in
Security, Blockchain,
Machine Learning, AI,
Cloud, everything systems.
Then Matei from
Stanford University.
Matei is a young faculty there.
He's already done amazing work.
His PhD thesis was among the
best read in recent times which
was on Apache Spark,
which led to Databricks.
So he released his code
that started as part of
a PhD thesis which received
the ACM Best Dissertation Award,
this was at least as open source.
Since then, he's actually
founded the startup which
is doing super well,
which has raised
over $200 million,
and has several customers,
and it's on Azure as well.
It's one of the course
along with Databricks.
So, welcome again for
this exciting discussion.
So one of the things as
systems researchers,
we run into is all of
us who do research,
want to build systems that
is used by a lot of people.
We want it to scale out,
we want it to be adopted
out there in the world.
There are multiple
ways to do that.
All of us at some point think
that, "Hey, you know what?
It's ready, we are ready
to take this out."
The few ways you can
actually take it out to
multiple people is either you can
release it as open source.
My adviser Ken Burman had
recently written blog on that,
how do you venture
to Open-Source,
your solutions either Open-Source
or you could license it out.
There various faculty
who've done very well by
licensing out the technology like
Guri Sohi from Wisconsin.
Or the third, which
both of you have
done which is to do a startup.
So, what made you decide,
don't worry I have to first
ask you this question since
you've done one star
developed another.
When did you decide that
you are ready to do a startup and
why start-up why not license it
out or put your code
out as Open-Source?
>> So different researchers have
different preferences and for
me I was feeling
that as a researcher
not only did I want to build
new technologies and
really excited about
the innovation from
the technical perspective
and also at the same time
I feel as a researcher
often we do
have a responsibility
to take our creations,
our new technologies into
the real world to help
change the world,
to help improve the world.
With that I think I enjoy
the process of seeing and also
the journey of taking the
technology that we developed
in the lab and actually into
the real world to see it.
Also that's a great way as
a first hence and you can
see out what needs
to be improved in
the technology that you have
developed and how to
make it even better.
I think all these are great
research to actually do it to
faster hands and also as
technology innovators.
Oftentimes, you are the one who
actually understands
the technology best
and hence you know
what's the best way
to adjust and adapt
to the real world,
use cases and to find the
best product market fits.
>> So, this is a good answer.
This is something which
propels me as well
doing PVC with TV white spaces
all with FarmBeats.
Success is not just
writing a paper,
it's actually getting it out
into the hands of everyone.
This is a different principle
for some faculty it
could just be published
the paper someone
will pick it up.
So, Matei you've done both.
You released your code as
Open-Source which
has been a big hit
and you're also doing
a startup which is
another big success.
So, how did you decide but each
one of them which route to go?
And would your decision have
changed like with Spark?
Would you still have released
it as Open-Source of
back then you knew that
you were doing a startup?
>> Yeah. Good question yeah.
So, in general releasing
software as Open-Source from
research is a great way
to see whether people
can actually use it and
also engage with early users who
are willing to try it out
and give you feedback.
So, that was great.
I think for us one reason to
start a company around
it was actually
just to push it to
the next level.
So, Apache Spark
already had a bunch of
early users when we
decided to start the company
and it had some traction.
People were excited about it,
but in a university you have
limited resources to work on it.
So, we felt that as a company we
could actually invest
a lot more in it,
push it to the next
level and tackle
a whole new set of
problems with it.
That's exactly what
happened actually
since we started the company,
both what's in the software,
like the functionality
and features have
grown tremendously and also
the developer community
has grown tremendously and it's
definitely partly because
the company spent a lot of
time making sure it's super easy
for people to use and
to be successful with.
>> So, basically
what you're saying
is depending on your idea.
Depending on what you're doing,
you might want in some cases
to Open-Source it.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you even for
example you created
courses that are
on some of these.
And you have so many people
trained to use Apache Spark,
and how did that lead to
the success of Databrcks?
>> Yeah. That's a thing
that company did to
promote it and to
help people use it.
But if it is partly a matter
of scale as I said and it
depends on this after.
I mean this was basically
a distributed computing platform
and standard library
every data processing algorithm
you want to use giving you
a distributed version of it.
That's a pretty big effort.
There are some other for
it maybe you just build
a small Open-Source project
and it's going to be that way.
>> All right. That's
a good point.
So, the other question which
is related to this is,
how did you do that transition
once you wanted to
do this startup,
how did you go about doing it?
Did you- in some cases,
some academics are good
at doing research,
do you hire someone from
outside to be the CEO?
Run with it? Do you
do it yourself?
How do you build a team?
At what point, because
you still are students,
at what point do you
decide to take it
out versus just keep still
doing research on top,
building something solid
and how do you take it out?
How do you make it
into a startup?
When do you in cooperate?
When do you build a
startup out of it?
Dawn, why don't you start with
three experiences you
had, one after another.
You could start with the
first one in cyber security.
>> Yeah. Given that I've done
two and then now I'm
doing the third.
So, I do have a very broad
experience in this regard.
So, in terms of
whether we should hire
outside CEO or bringing
outside CEO and whether we
should do it ourselves.
So, in my case actually
we've done both.
For my first company as well as
the third company the one
that I'm doing right now,
always use the labs.
So, I'm the CEO, the
founder and CEO.
For the second company
Mendel security,
so that one we actually
have a great CEO
who has been running
it from very early on.
I think in different cases,
they actually both have
worked out really well.
So in the first case and
also for the third one,
so essentially these
are technologies.
Again as I mentioned one thing is
that as we develop
technologies, then.
Besides the technology side,
the biggest question is to
find product market fits and also
the CEO's job is
precise on hiring and
raising money is to
be able to carry out
the overall vision,
the direction for the company.
So oftentimes, it's bit tricky
for us as CEO who don't
understand the
technology well enough
to actually meet the vision
and also to even
find the good product market
fits because they may
not know the technology
enough to be able
to quickly figure
out what may be
the best product market fit.
So, in the first case
and the third case,
so I was able to allow the
CEO and it was difficult to,
I mean I was happy to do
it and also it's hard to
find other CEOs to
actually to do this.
I think we were very lucky
for the second case where,
I think just through chances we
were introduced
through friends and
the CEO Amiae and he has
a great track record and who was
already very successful as
an entrepreneur before,
who has done startup that
was acquired and so on.
Also the things that
he actually already
was passionate about
the space that we were in,
the technology that
we were developing,
he was actually
thinking even something
similar in that domain.
So, he already had
a very good understanding of
the space and his background,
he has done a ton of
enterprise sales in
his prior startups.
So, his background
is a great fit in
terms of really actually
helping to define
the product market fit and
also to take the product
really to enterprise
customers and really grow it.
He's really excited and
really passionate and
committed to take the technology
in a fully going forward.
>> Your involvement
is still there
as the technologist or?
In that particular case?
>> Luckily, and so another
Berkeley grad students,
we worked together
on this technology
and he actually has been
the co-founder and chief
architect of the technology,
and he's still as a company.
So, I think that really helps.
>> That's a good perspective.
Matei yourself,
you are still the chief
technologist at Databricks?
>> Yes.
>> Your CEO is again internal,
someone who was part
of the initial team?
So how did you decide
that experience mainly
in the context of
the audience who are faculty,
some of them might want
to become entrepreneurs,
so even license that idea out or
to hire people to take
their ideas to scale.
>> Yeah. Well, I think again,
I think the reason to do it
yourself is if you
have a vision for it,
maybe only you can
execute or can see
and it's really
hard to get someone
else to do it and especially
also to hire someone who is very
good to do that because maybe
it hasn't been validated but
do you really believe in it.
I think that's
the reason to do it.
My experience was a little
different in a few ways,
so one thing is I was
just finishing my PhD,
so I didn't have my own
research group at the time.
So, that made it easier
to take some time
off completely and just
work on the startup.
Also, we started with a bunch
of co-founders actually from
the same research group,
including my two advisers
and a lot of students
and Ali Ghodsi,
who is the CEO now,
who was a visiting researcher
working in distributed systems.
So, we already had a pretty
tight-knit team that had
worked together for years and
could work well together.
We definitely learned
a lot of stuff,
we had some people on
the team like Ali and Yance
and Scott who had
startup experience and we
had others like me
who didn't but,
we had enough critical mass
to build things and
to show promise of
our idea and to
be able to hire the right people
in the other roles
at the company.
>> Wonderful. So, then
about raising money which
is related to this,
so when you're in the valley
but even then so a lot
of startups that we see are
either business
model innovations.
These are the ones that
maybe in the social space,
there's no technical
meet behind it
but for most people
in this audience,
these are really strong
technical contributions,
papers in the top
tier conferences.
Do you think these kind of
technical contributions
have been going out to
VCs to raise money,
do you see it making
it easier for you to
get into this space to kick
off the startup process?
In particular Dawn,
I wanted to ask you,
we've been hearing a lot
of comments around,
a lot of news articles around
women finding it hard,
women entrepreneurs
finding it hard to
raise money in the valley.
Did you face any of that? Do
you have any recommendations
for female faculty in
the audience who would like
to become entrepreneurs?
Both questions together, right?
So, maybe it's easier for
female faculty because
it's coming in with
a technical background and
some suggestions
that you might have.
>> Yeah. I think it
definitely today,
we do have advantage that
we are technologists,
so we already have developed
innovative technologies that
usually when we started company,
so we have three cases,
there are technologies that
me and my group has
developed in my lab
and we see the potential
and then we are
excited about the
technology transfer and
then we decided to
do the company.
So, in this case, unlike
many and other entrepreneurs,
when we go out,
we actually already have
the initial technology that
have already been developed.
So, that I think it definitely,
both from fundraising perspective
and also even from just
bringing up the team
where they have a great team
and the co-team
are really passionate and
excited about the technology
that we have been building.
In certain cases,
it take four years.
So, I think that's a great start.
That's like a greater start
than many of the other types
of entrepreneurs, companies.
As a women entrepreneur,
I think so, first of all,
so we're just labs we just
raised our funding recently,
we made the announcement,
we raised 45 million.
>> Congratulations.
>> Yeah. Thank you and
we also raised it in
a very short period of
time and we have top
of the line like great investors
including Ann Jason and
Exel and many other.
>> That's awesome.
>> All right. Investors.
So, for me I think,
I was a pretty smooth process
and also in particular I
think actually as
a woman entrepreneur,
we do have certain
advantages too,
in the sense that
they actually have
quite a few friends
who are women like
VCs who run their funds and also
other male VCs who run funds.
There are a number of
them who actually have
strong intent and support
for women entrepreneurs.
>> That's really good.
>> So, fundraising, I
think I've been lucky
that the people that I have seen,
they have been really supportive
for women entrepreneurs.
>> So, female faculty,
please reach out to Dawn
for any recommendations
of who to reach to.
>> Yeah. Happy to help.
>> Matei, did you have
to do any fundraising
yourself or it's usually
the CEO who does it,
how often do you have
to face the investors?
>> Yeah. All the co-founders were
involved in it and especially
at the beginning, I think.
But I think the people
who want to do it,
I mean I'll say
a couple of things.
So, one thing is
anything you can do that
shows validation
of your technology
as in someone would actually buy
it or even use it
is super important.
So, just having a paper
at a top conference,
they don't really know
how to judge you, I mean,
they'll be happy to
grab coffee with
you and talk because
their job is to go
talk to lots of
interesting people in
the technology space but
they don't really know.
But if you say, "Okay.
There's someone using it."
Maybe someone in your university,
maybe someone who used
the opensource thing,
and so on and they asked them and
they find it's solving
a real problem,
that makes it a lot
easier for them.
So, for us, we had
opensource Spark software
and it was very
easy for the VCs to
see that it's useful
because a lot of the portfolio
companies we're already using it,
because they were startups
who try out it's kind
of crazy new technology,
but that's what I would go for.
Definitely, even if you
don't know some some
of the top VCs,
I'm sure you know
other faculty members
who know them and you can get
an introduction through them and
I think that will also carry
a lot of weight if
someone they know says,
"Oh, you got to talk to so and so
because I think they have
something interesting.".
>> That's sweet feedback.
So, users are important.
Do they have to be paying
or do they have to at
least have paying potential
or just demo would be fine?
>> Well, I think it's good
if they actually use it to
do something valuable
and you could ask them,
"Is this actually
valuable to you?"
They don't have to
be paying but they
have to think it's useful.
>> Okay. Great feedback.
So, yes, so a followup question,
which I think would
be in the mind
of many of the people
in the audiences.
You guys are running
successful startups right now,
both of them have raised
quite a bit of money.
How has any of
this entrepreneurship
affected your research career
positively and negatively, right?
So, both ways how has it made
your research stronger or weaker?
What your opinions?
Dawn, you could start,
you've gone through it three
times, and you're tenured,
you have everything
in your table,
you can say whatever you want.
>> Okay. So, in general the
answer of course is positive.
I think, again, also people
do things differently
and there are
different startups that I
think it's a very broad spectrum.
So, in my case,
also because my research
area is really broad,
and the three startups,
they're actually in
very different areas.
The first one was
in mobile security.
The second one was
in secure browsing.
Then the third one
is block chain.
Also overall, my research
is very broad.
So none of these I would
say in my case and
not necessarily the particular
technical things that I
learned from one company
influenced the next one,
because again as I mentioned,
I enjoy working at
different areas.
But what I would say as really
the experience that I have
gained through doing
the startups that really,
I think that's another reason
that I actually enjoyed this.
I view it's, again,
I think many of us here
are growth minded.
Like we are here to really
to grow, to become better,
and I think being a professor
and being a researcher,
that's a great way for
us to learn and grow.
On the other hand, being
an entrepreneur is
a great way to learn and
grow and it's very
complimentary to what
we typically do as
a researcher, as a faculty.
Hence, for that, I
think in general,
what I have benefited from
the entrepreneurship experience
is that it really
helps me to be stronger
in these other dimension,
that normally we don't get to
exercise our experience,
and overall,
that does help provide
a broader perspective and
when I then choose
research topics,
I want to work in research and
also in terms of after being
more effective as well.
>> Because this is a pattern
in the startups that you do.
You start a new research team,
get some publications
out, do a start-up,
get it acquired or
something and then
come back do another research
which is great,
you are scaling up your your
research through startups.
>> Middy, your response
to this question?
>> Yeah, I mean I think
for me being part of
a startup has been
incredibly helpful and
seen real-world problems as
they arise and basically
finding new research areas
that I know are important
because I've experienced
the problem more
like our customers
have experienced the problem,
but that are maybe
harder for people to
see or to even
understand in academia.
Some of them, you
probably can't do at all
unless you actually
work with customers.
So, and these can be
very general problems,
you should often not be
specific to
a particular customer.
So just as an example,
database sells
only a cloud product.
It's basically
software as a service
on Amazon Web Services or Azure
and the vast majority
of the revenue is just
licensing fees of
using the software.
It's not support or
consulting or anything.
So it's got to build
a really good software
as a service cloud product,
that small [inaudible] ,
secure and performer
and highly available,
and building that is really
hard and this is actually the way
the vast majority of
new enterprise software today
and even consumer software,
software as a service
and I don't know
any university class that
teaches you how to build it.
I don't see any papers
at conferences that
actually say here are
the problems in terms
of building it,
or like here's
our new abstraction that you
can use to deploy
SaaS or whatever.
It's just an interesting thing
to think about if
people are going to keep building
computer systems in
the future this way,
we'd better understand
how to do it.
So a lot of the kind
of problems I
think about in research
are inspired by that,
while you see something was
super hard like it literally
took three years to get
right for database.
It's got to be hard
for anyone else.
Is there any way to
make that easier?
>> This is great, so essentially
what you're seeing is that
both the startup
experiences helping
enrich your research career.
So I'll bring up
the negative part of it.
So this is slightly
controversial, well,
but in a positive way
that one of the questions
I asked both Middy and
Dawn internally was, well,
it's a full-time job
running a startup
being I'm doing
being in academia,
how do you manage it more
than with like well we
spend 80 percent of
the time doing a startup,
80 percent of the doing academia.
So that's the time
we'd have zero time.
So my question is more around,
how do you manage
time for yourself,
not about researcher startups,
what is your me time and what
do you do in your me time?
Any tips for people
who want to do both,
and still have a me time?
Dawn, why don't you start?
>> That's a very good question,
I wish there was
a great answer to it,
because I asked
the same question and I think
especially so I'm facing of
right now with our startups.
We are growing very fast
and and there's
a lot of examines,
and we're talking to actually
a lot of potential
customers as well,
and there's just so much to do,
and that they just.
>> What do you do outside
of work? How do you relax?
>> Actually, so earlier,
I was taking fencing lessons.
>> That helps, that
helps even with me.
>> No, I just
figured somehow I actually
enjoyed fencing as a sport,
and then weekends
actually I do go
running on the beach
when I have time.
>> Yeah, Middy, any
tips from your side?
I know it's even busier
for you, eight students,
managing the startups,
doing writing really
quality papers,
you have been very prolific.
>> I think Dawn has
a lot of students too.
>> Yeah, she has
eight students as well,
she fences with them and
they are very loose.
What do you do?
>> I mean my feeling on
this is even just academic
job alone or just a startup job
alone can easily
consume all your time.
So, in a sense,
you'd have the same problem
in either case,
and you have to,
in both cases, you have to
be mindful of your time,
understand what's the best way
for you to spend stuff,
when should you take time
off to do something else,
when should you delegate,
when you should evaluate
what you're doing,
seeing is this actually
the right way to spend my time?
What's actually most
important to spend time on?
So I think it's not that they
are different, but you do,
you have to expect that
things will be
somewhat hectic and I
think anyone who does either of
these two jobs
really enjoys them.
I don't think anyone
starts a tenure-track,
faculty job without
enjoying data,
or a startup for instance.
>> So this is the
same in a research
lab and sitting here
and telling you.
We're here, we do it,
we work extra hours.
It's because we enjoy doing what
we do with any of these
[inaudible] project is about.
We do it because we know
eventually it'll have bombers
and that's why the entire team
just works the extra hours,
weekends getting things
up. This is great.
So now, going to
another question which is
around both of you
who are very successful
as entrepreneurs,
and one is from Berkeley,
the others from Stanford,
and you're from Berkeley as well.
>> Yeah.
>> Is there something in
the water of the bay area,
the scarcity of water
in the bay area
or is there something else
that makes that schools
there more successful,
other things that
other schools could learn,
other than proximity to
the VCs that are there,
is there something else that
the university enables
for faculty to
do more startups of really
scale up startups? So, Dawn?
>> I think probably the biggest
thing is the ecosystem,
and assuming the barrier,
I think there's
a great ecosystem for
doing startups and also
it's I guess the mindset
and the people that you
interact with often,
they are, I guess
the concentration of
entrepreneur-minded
people probably is
fairly high in the bay area,
and of course it
has a great setup.
There is the density of
the sea and all that,
and also Yes, I
think maybe there's also
a little bit of a self-selection.
>> Among the VC's you mean?
>> I think, again,
that can even be area.
People who go to the area.
>> I see.
>> Also there is bits in
malls and say like tips.
>> All right.
>> All right thanks.
>> But if it's Stanford,
we see so many of them so what?
>> Yeah, I think so far.
>> Basically you see a lot too.
>> Yeah.
>> I was from Berkeley as well.
>> Right.
>> We have two Berkeley
people out there.
>> Yes.
>> You were are
a wealthy person, Yes.
>> Yeah, but the start
up started from there.
>> That's true.
>> Yeah, being in debate is
definitely good for
connections and also
for hiring people who've
been out startups and so on.
It does help with that.
There are communities
and other cities
and other area that still
don't know if it can do it.
So, it can be done but
it definitely helps.
I think the other thing is having
a supportive department and
department chair and so on.
But, I think most universities do
want to see successful
startups come out of it,
but you want to make sure
that they let you do it,
that you're not
penalized in some way.
>> So, when you say support from
the department, such as what?
>> Well, so for example,
can you go on leave for
some time to do it,
can you go on partial leave
maybe because you have
students you want to
continue supporting them and
doing research, these
types of things.
Sometimes it can be
inflexible because
of policies or
bureaucracy sometimes.
They'll push through and
make sure if they think it's
impactful that you can do it.
>> Yes.
>> Very many Universities
strive to enable that.
>> Related question.
So, as big companies as
us here at Microsoft,
how can we enable
more such successful
entrepreneurs
from various universities,
not just Berkeley and Stanford,
but universities at
other places as well?
Would you have any suggestions
on what companies like
Microsoft can do? Go on.
>> Okay. As I suppose
giving more money.
I think that might help.
I think Microsoft, it's
just any big company actually
has a lot of advantages,
that has a lot of
value that they can
provide to future entrepreneurs,
to faculty who want to
become entrepreneurs later.
So for example, Microsoft
also sees a lot of problems.
So, it knows which problems
at pinpoints to focus and
which ones may have a big blanket
that actually need
new technologies,
and I think Faculty
and Researchers
are always in love to learn
about these type problems
and also Microsoft
has a great platform.
If anyone develops
a new technology,
Microsoft offers a great
platform that can introduce
this technology to a lot of
users and companies and so on,
can really help
a new technology to
be adopted and to grow.
So, I think that can
be really helpful.
>> Do you want to add
something to that, Marty?
>> Yeah, I think beyond
funding which is
definitely super
important both for
research actually the areas that
you think they are
impactful for companies,
I think Microsoft is
interesting because it has
wide reach into enterprises
in pretty much any areas,
any business partnerships with
startups that will be
impactful and I think those
already existed in
many areas of Microsoft.
Maybe people don't know how to
approach those or how
to get one started,
but they do make a difference
early on and they can help
you validate your idea and
be good basically for
both sides of the partnership.
>> So, how can Microsoft
approach these?
So, both of you said that
we are great at reach out,
but what is
a good medium to reach
out to these entrepreneurs
to the startup?
Is it through courses, students,
do you have any suggestions,
or how do we engage better
with such budding startups,
or then maybe co-marketing
events or things like that?
>> Yeah.
>> Anyway, while we are coming
to the end of the time,
just any parting
thoughts on faculty
here who might be thinking
about taking that idea
out and scaling it out
through a startup? So, Don.
>> Yeah, that's simple question.
I think one is that,
entrepreneurship is
something really fun to try.
Of course it's also very
high in terms of duty,
it takes a lot of time and you
have to focus a lot on it,
and also people do
read many papers but not
everything on paper is
necessarily something that you
may want to turn
it into a startup.
So typically for startup,
we want technology
that's both innovative,
so that gives you an edge
and also you need to
be really practical enough
that actually can be
used in the real world.
So, many papers that
we write about,
it has new ideas that
really are cool ideas but
it may still be at
the very early stage that's
not practical enough yet.
So those are probably not
ready for doing a startup yet.
Also I think they need to
resolve a big enough problem
that people are
willing to pay for it,
and has a big enough market
and I think it as faculty
and researchers who
are looking at starting
their company or trying
to see which technology
that they have developed,
they may want to take
into the markets,
that is something
helpful to keep in mind.
>> Okay. Marty got
something to say?
>> Yeah, the reasons to
do are basically impact
and also ability to
work on problems that
maybe would be harder
to work on in academia.
So these are both
good reasons to do it.
It is a lot of
work, as Dawn said,
and it's a large commitment
and it will take
more time than you
expect even if you take
just a little bit of
time sabbatical or whatever
and then you want to go back.
If things are going
well you'll want to
continue being involved and
they'll be a lot of
things you can do.
So, it is a somewhat
large commitment.
But on the other hand,
you can really see
things that you
wouldn't see outside,
and especially if you
find a good team you
have investors or partners
who can help get things started,
they can accelerate that
because it's also their job to
help you make those connections
and get those other users.
>> Thank you Marty and Don,
and we will in
the bus for dinner.
Feel free to ask us questions,
hope you all enjoyed
this session.
If you have any more
questions, we'd love to
carry on the discussion
over dinner.
Thank you everyone. Thank you.
>> Thank you.